Trey,
my day,
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day is,
I think I remember you're
seeing short careers anyways.
Yeah.
Like to me this,
this and I feel the same
way as you guys do with,
it's sad the way Rhonda lost what's not
that sad because she had such a great
run.
She was a pioneer.
She was on the Mount
Rushmore of MMA in general.
She goes on Mount restaurant.
It's really not that sad.
Like God damn,
what are iconic run man.
Sad is like you've got like more
coalminer or a guy like if Mark Hunt word
retire like that.
Sad people don't have money and fame.
She set man.
It's not that sad.
She did some great shit.
A great things.
You know what's interesting
here is going on,
it's like the Ronda fans,
um,
they're not MMA fans.
A lot of them,
they're Ronda fans and so like you see
how they respond to stuff on Twitter and
you see like the reaction of
the things that they're saying.
Like it's pretty emotional.
It's very emotional.
It's also almost like
they don't understand.
They don't understand the sport.
You know,
get back on the horse.
Like,
Whoa,
fuck the horse.
No,
listen to your mom,
your mom,
your mom saying stop.
Her mom's brilliant.
Yeah,
her mom's,
her mom's brutal.
She so brutal.
She says,
she goes,
go let stupid people
get punched in the face.
Sorry.
Stupid people.
Her,
her mom,
her mom's brilliant and she's a doctor
and the good thing for Rhonda to add all
of this is she's going to
find out who's in her corner.
There's been,
there's been so many.
Yes men.
You know how it is in Holland.
There's nothing when you're on set,
you know bullshit is your agents.
These other people you're working
with these other celebrities,
Tony,
all good Ui.
Well now when you lose that,
that phone stops ringing
and the tech stop coming.
Everyone asks you to Denver.
That stuff you're going to
find out who's in your corner.
That's probably,
they might be good for now.
Let me ask you,
do the last two years,
because I heard they cut a one
and the other one disappeared.
Who knows?
Who knows what kind of deal she has,
but things definitely dried
up substantially after
the Holly knockout because
she's not the same person anymore.
The thing about all those deals is when
you're a winner in Hollywood and they
start throwing all these movies at you
and you're some athletes coming over,
it's all predicated on you being
that person that they're selling,
right?
What are they selling?
They're selling this
undefeated women's ass kicker.
The likes,
if you've never seen before,
right?
Throwing people in their head,
get him in an arm bar.
That's what they're selling.
Well,
that's not you anymore.
Now you just got smashed by Holly and
then smashed again by a man and they can't
sell your acting abilities to,
she'd be waiting to,
she'd do roadhouse.
Did she redo roadhouse done?
They killed.
I don't know about any of that stuff.
I,
I just know to,
to his point where they're,
it's,
it's almost a good thing for it.
It really is,
man.
It's not a sad story.
I don't find it as a sad story.
I really don't.
Well,
it's definitely sad and she was an angel.
It's not the sadness.
When she disappeared,
Bro,
she came,
goes,
she leaves it all that much different.
Do we feel safe for tiger woods like that?
Like I said,
when that foundation rocks,
like what do you think's
different with Tiger's swing?
No,
the difference.
You can get the fuck beat
out of them and 48 seconds.
I know and that's fighting,
but what I'm saying is there
hadn't mentality changes
when tiger on stoppable he
something happened.
He's had that.
He had the the scandal.
Yes,
but then he also has some
significant back injuries.
Correct.
Or what our K for better
example to your fight example.
Mike Tyson.
Yeah.
That's also wear and tear too,
man.
Yeah.
You can say that for Rhonda
tickets waiting to tell you why.
I can say that.
One of the reasons why is because the
driver that I had this weekend in Vegas
that took me to the airport was
Mike Tyson's driver for 17 years.
I had a long conversation.
Cool Dude.
I wish I could remember his fucking name.
I only met him for that brief
brief ride to the airport,
but he was telling me how fucked up
Tyson was after the Lennox Lewis fight.
He's like,
dude,
Lennox Lewis hit Mike and Mike was
fucked up for a long time for shit.
And you don't think that you
watch a guy get knocked out,
you watch guy get stopped.
And you know,
Mike was talking after
the fight and he was like,
Hey,
you know I'm,
I'm done.
It's over and eaten a step back.
But when he goes home and he's alone
and the cameras are off and he's got
vertigo and he's got equilibrium problems
and his ears won't stop ringing in his
head,
won't stop throbbing.
You don't see that he's doing interviews.
His head's throb and his ears are ringing.
There was no internet back then.
It's harder.
It's harder to hide nowadays.
You know what I mean?
Hard.
You've got your daily thing
that you do and everybody,
you got your followers and they all know
your daily thing and you guys are doing
the daily things.
All of a sudden he disappeared.
Everybody knows he
disappeared and back then,
no one really knew you lost the fight.
You never really see him again.
Like when he was also like,
when you're suffering alone,
the only way people find
out is if you talk about it.
Like we don't know what happens to a lot
of these guys after they get beat the
fuck up.
[inaudible].